[موسيقى]
مسلمون باطني توزعوا بين تركيا وسوريا
ولبنان اجمعوا على التوحيد وعلى مكان خاصه
للامام علي بن ابي طالب اتحدث عن العلويين
التقيه في عقيدتهم والسريه في طقوسهم
ومشهد سياسي معقد في الشرق الاوسط جعلهم
محطه صور نمطيه وتاويله فاخرج العلويون من
عباءه الاسلام تاره وقيل انهم يمارسون
سفاح القرب تاره اخرى وتم تكفيرهم
والتنكيل بم زارتهم وفي بدايه القرن
الواحش نسال الا يجب ان يرى المسلمون في
تنوع مذاهبهم عظمه وثراء وتجس للديمقراطيه
في عصر الدول الحديثه ولان الجهل هو عدو
التعايش ماذا يعرف الشارع العربي عن
الطائفه العلويه في فلك الممنوع
[موسيقى]
لنشاهد تمدد العلويه من داخل تركيا لا
داخل سوريا داخل العراق مسلمين زي ما احنا
مسلمين ولكنهم انحرفوا عن مسار الامام علي
عندما حصلت المشكله في معركه صفين تقريبا
هي طوائف زرعت لاجل التفريق بين المسلمين
لاجل زرع الخلاف والتفرقه من المسلمين
اللي بعرف مشهور فيهم بس الفنان فريد
الاطرش الناس يعني محتاره فيهم ديانتهم
تختلف عن ديانتنا انز تقريبا شبه المسلمين
المسيحيين ايش زي هيك يمكن اقليه هم دهم
قليل بس هم البيئه الحاكمه بسوريا ههم
مسلمين وبيا امنوا بالامام علي يمكن ما
هيك نحن ببيروت ما بنعرف شي عنه حافظ
الاسد بشار الاسد ه ه علويين ههم الاصل
برزد
الاسد هو اكثر شخص بيخطر ببالي هو احدا من
العلويين بيخطر على فكري [__] الثوره
السوريه بايام الفرنسيين كانوا علويين
ومته ددين من سيره
دعش وهم مش شيعه اقليه هي اقليه ربما لها
من الحنكه او من الشرعيه الدينيه ما
يجعلها تتحكم القبيله العلويه معت تحكم في
سوريا
دبوي 70 سنه عندهم من اللي استقلوا من
حافر الاسد اصبحت عندها علاقه سياسيه مع
ايران علاقه دبلوماسيه كبيره هم كانوا
اتباع سيدنا علي تمام كده وخرجوا من
الخوارج اللي هم ايه رفضوا اللي هو ايه
الصلح انا اعرف ان هم الموحدين انا متاكد
من المعلومه دي هو 10% من طوائف سوريا
العلويين دول بس هي الفكره ها ان هم
منتشرين قوي يعني بشار الاسد وده اكبر
حاجه يمكن وكان والده علوي برض وديت من
الطائفه اللي هي يعتبر قر من الروافد شويه
الطائفه العلويه هي طائفه يقال بانها
تنتسب للصحابي علي بن ابي طالب من الطوائف
التي ظهرت في منطقه على ما اعتقد انطاكيا
في الشرق الاوسط وسوريا
و يبدو اعتقد ان النسبه الاكبر من معتنقي
هذه الطائفه في في تركيا وفي مصر
بصراحه الطائفه العلويه في المغرب مايش
ماشي معلومات عليها كثير ومن بين يعني
ابرز الشخصيات المعتنق لهذا المذهب الديني
يعني الرئيس السوري بشار
[موسيقى]
الاسد هم اقرب ها الى ال العلمانيه
واليسار يعني يبوحوا كلكل شيء عندهم
الخمر النساء مثل انهم لا يعترفون بالكعبه
انص تكليف عندهم من 40 سنه المح المحللين
الخمر
وال بيمشوا مع سيدنا علي
وبمن طبعا بالاسلام مسلمين بس لهم طقوس
مختلفه عنا السني معروف سني الشيعي معروف
الشيعي اما هذول العلويين مش معروفين يعني
عندهم طقوس غريبه ولهم اشياء ذاتهم يعني
لا ما بتبعهم بيحكوا عن حالهم مسلمين بس
انا ما بعتبرهم من المسلمين جماعه لها
مبادئها واعتقاداته الخاصه فقط بس بقولوا
هن اسلام بصلوا صوموا بوحده بيعترفوا بس
هن مربين الامام علي عليه السلام قد يكون
هناك بعض الاراء عنهم انه يبالغون بحب علي
فقالوا يبالغون في حب علي حتى كفروا وهن
بالتاكيد مسلمين هن بقولوا انه ههم مسلمين
ويتصرفوا
كمسلمين [__] معتدلين معناتها مش كما
السلفيين والوحده الطاف العلويه معناها
الدين تعها الاسلام ما بيمن بالصحابه وما
بيؤمن بالدين الاسلامي او السني بصح بيكن
محبه خاصه وانتماء خاص للامام علي بن ابي
طالب ربما يختلفون مع السنه في بعض
الممارسات الدينيه لكن بصفه عامه يعني هم
تبقى طري يعني هم طائفه دينيه مختلفه عن
السنه في الكثير من
[موسيقى]
الاشياء مشاهدينا في ظل وضع سياسي معقد
وحساس اردنا من هذه الحلقه ان تكون بابا
للتع بالطائف العلويه اجتماعيا وثقافيا
لذا يسعدنا ان نستضيف في الاستديو المؤرخ
والكاتب والاكاديمي عبد الله نعمان استاذ
عبد الله اهلا بك نشرت مؤخرا كتابا شيقا
يحمل عنوان العلويون وهي دراسه تاريخيه
هذا هو الكتاب اذا نشاهده على الشاشه
اهديت هذا الكتاب الى روح زميلك على مقاعد
الدراسه العلوي جوده مرعي نعم اسمح لي في
البدايه في هذه الحلقه ان اطرح عليك بعض
الاسئله العلميه التي ستساعد نا وتساعد
المشاهدين على تاطير هذا النقاش لاحقا
اتمنى ان تكون الاجابات مختصره لو سمحت
بدايه من اين اتى العلويون ومن
هم هناك غموض في كما ونفس الغموض موجود في
سائر الطوائف التي نشات بعد ظهور الاسلام
ام العلويون باختصار شديد انتسبوا في
البدايه الى محمد ابن نصير ولهذا السبب
كانوا يدعون النصير
ام وهو احد
تلاميذ الامام العاشر عفوا الحادي عشر ام
الهادي الهادي ولكن يبدو انه تمرد عليه
وفضل ان
ينتسب
الى الامام الثاني عشر اها
اي
العسكري كان اسمه العسكري
وا الاهم من ذلك انه اعتبر بفتره معينه
انه هو كذلك
اصبح نبي العلويون اليوم يدخلون خانه
المسلمين المقربين الى طائفه الشيعيه قطعا
العلويون مسلمون لا شك ام مسلمون جعفريون
اي يتبعون في الامور
الاساسيه الامام جعفر الصادق
و ويتبعون من الناحيه
الفقهيه مذهب الجعفري المعروف بالاضافه
الى
المذاهب المذاهب السنيه الاربعه ط سؤالي
يعني بسرعه لماذا يمارسون الطقيه ولا
ينشرون كتبهم ومعتقداتهم تعلمين ان في
الشرق الاوسط كل الطوائف التي انبثقت من
الاسلام كما تلك التي انبثقت من اليهوديه
والمسيحيه وسائر
الديانات الموحده وغير الموحده اي كانت
تبتعد مع الزمن
من الاصل
الاساسي السني اذا شئتي
وا الفروقات البسيطه في البدايه تضخمت مع
الوقت نعم فاصبح
مثلا تدخل القوى الاجنبيه وخصوصا الغرب مع
الصليبيين ثم مع الفرنسيين والانجليز
وسائر شعوب الشعوب المسيحيه في حوض البحر
المتوسط حاولت حاول هذه القوى في القرن في
القرون الوسطى ان تجلب اليها كل هذه
الطوائف الصغيره
على لتطبيق القول الشائع فرق تسد نعم
فلهذا مثلا الفرنسيون ومنهم علماء كبار
قالوا للنصيري
انتم كلمه نصير لا تاتي من محمد ابن نصير
وانما من
نصراني من
المسيحيين ولهذا يعني هناك الكثير من من
المغالطات ربما
ح سؤال الاخير لك استاذ عبد الله
يعني يعيشون اليوم في تركيا بالغالب
الساحقه في تركيا وفي سوريا وفي لبنان
علوي وتركيا هل يختلفون باختصار عن علويين
سوريا هناك اختلاف بعض الاختلافات ويمكن
ان نقول انهم اولاد العم اذا شئتي كي لا
ادخل في التفاصيل طيب لن نناقش في هذه
الحلقه خصوصيات علويه تركيا نظرا ل الوقت
ولانها تستحق حلقه كامله طبعا من بيروت
مشاهدينا عبر الاقمار الصناعيه معنا الشيخ
علي قدور احد علماء الطائفه الاسلاميه
العلويه في لبنان حضره الشيخ اشكرك على
حضورك معنا اليوم سؤالي الاول
لك انتم العلويون انتم مسلمون تؤمنون
بالاركان الخمسه للاسلام العلويون هم
مسلمون ينتمون ولاء لامير المؤمنين علي بن
ابي طال طالب عليه سلام الله نحن كنا وما
زلنا نحن مسلمون
علويون الله ربنا والاسلام ديننا والقران
كتابنا ام ولماذا كل هذه السريه فيما
يتعلق يعني بمعتقدات العلويين والوس لا
يوجد لا يوجد سريه على الاطلاق عند
المسلمين العلويين فان كتبهم مشهوره ام
فضلا عن شهره علمائهم واد
وهذا معروف
ومشهور فان عدم رؤيه حضره الشيخ عدم رؤيه
الشمس لا يدل على عدم وجودها اريد
انه مهمه جدا هناك مغالطات باختصار لو
سمحت هنا من بعد اذنكم اعطيني مجال للتكلم
تفضل
باختصار اولا ان عمليه او ان الكلام على
ان العلويين نشاوا منذ العصر الذي كان فيه
محمد بن نصير هذا كلام غير صحيح ارجعوا
الى كتب التاريخ تجدين هذه الروايه مثبته
عن فراد بن احنث ان رسول الله صلوات الله
عليه واله قال عن شيعه علي الا ان شيعه
علي يقولون يوم القيامه نحن العلويون
فتقول لهم الملائكه فانتم الامنون لا خوف
عليكم ولا انتم تحزنون تميه العلويين هي
تسميه كانت على عهد رسول الله صلوات الله
عليه واله النقطه الثانيه ط ان ان السيد
ابا شعيب محمد بن نصير ليس صاحب دين مستقل
عن الاسلام وليس صاحب مذهب مستقل ومنفرد
ومتميز عن الائمه المعصومين هذا كلام خطا
من اخي الاستاذ عبد الله نعمان السيد ابو
شعيب محمد بن نصير هو من
خواص الائمه المعصومين اعني بهم الامام
محمد الجواد والامام علي الهاد والامام
الحسن الاخير العسكري الذي عاش معهم واحدا
و
عاما وكل ما قيل عن العلويين هو غير صحيح
نحن يا اختي الكريمه نحن يا اختي الكريمه
نتيجه الاضطهاد والتعذيب والظلم التاريخ
الذين عبر قرون عبر ق كنا نمارس التقيه اي
كنا نخفي ولاءنا للائمه المعصومين طيب على
النفس خوفا وصلت فكرتك حضره الشيخ دع ليست
مبدا عند
العلويين ورده في القران الكريم الا ان
تتقوا منهم تقات انا اظهر انا اظهر خلاف
ما اعتقد خوفا من الطها طيب دعنا نذهب
حضره الشيخ الى في رحله ميدانيه الى جبل
محسن مرتفع صغير في شبال لبنان سكنه
العلويون منذ قرون كثر الحديث عنه في
وسائل الاعلام خلال السنوات الاخيره اثر
اشتباكات وقعت بين العلويين من اهل هذا
الجبل ومنطقه ملاصقه تدعى باب التبانه
تسكنها غالبيه سنيه اشتباكات خلفيتها
سياسيه متعلقه بالازمه السوريه كيف يعيش
العلويون في جبل محسن وماذا يقول محيطهم
عنهم التقرير خاص بفرس
24 جبل محسن اكبر تجمع للطائفه الاسلاميه
العلويه في شمال لبنان منذ قرون على هذا
المرتفع الصغير يعيش اليوم اكثر من 50 الف
علوي في ثلاثه كيل مترات مربعه مجموعه من
المغالطات احاطت بمعتقداتهم على مر العصور
لتقرب حينا من حضن الاسلام وتبعدهم عنه
احيانا اخرى الافتراءات قائمه على بعض
الفتاوى القديمه والتي ما زالت موجوده حتى
اليوم بالنسبه لموضوع الخمر هذه الحاله
موجوده لدى جميع الطوائف هناك من يرتدي
الحجاب وهناك من لا يرتدي الحجاب هذا
الامر
متروك لراي الامراه في الطائفه الاسلاميه
العلويه جزيره جبل محسن كما يصفها
العلويون تقع ضمن محيط سني شهدت عبر
السنوات مدا وجزرا على المستوى الامني لكن
بالنسبه الى حسان كل الاتهامات التي توجه
الى سكان جبل محسن ليست الا محاولات
سياسيه لتوتير
المنطقه معظم الشارع الطرابلسي يحتضن جبل
محسن وابناء جبل محسن والطائفه الاسلاميه
العلويه كاخوه في الدين الواحد
ولكن يوجد هناك بعض
الاصوات القليله جدا الذين ينفذون اجندات
سياسيه من اجل خلق فتنه بين ابناء الدين
الواحد ابناء الدين الواحد يفصلهم شارع
واحد بين منطقه التبانه وجبل محسن شارع
يفصل العلوي عن السني الا ان التداخل
الاجتماعي بين السكان حاضر تاريخيا فما
الذي يقوله المسلمون السنه في محيط جبل
محسن بنصوم مع بعض ونصلي مع بعض وبنصب مع
بعض واللي بيصوم بيصوم لحاله واللي ما
بيصلي ما بيصلي لحاله كل عملنا من من
ابتداء من حرب الاهليه من وجود العلويه
فوق ويعني نحن مهرين من بعضنا بصلي مع بعض
ونصوم مع بعض بنفطر مع بعض وبنسهر بالقوي
على الضم والفرز مع بعضنا يعني ما في شيء
لحتى يجمعنا معهم هذا رمضان بتعرفي انت
شهر فضيل اول شغله نحن ما عم نقول ما في
منكر وما كان في منكر بس اليوم في شيء هم
عندهم ظاهر العلوي هو مسلم
مثله مثل السني مثل الشيعي مثل انه اي حدا
اختلاف في التصنيف الطائفي واحيانا
السياسي بين التبانه واجب المحسن الا ان
ما يجمعهما حتما هو فقر متقع وتهميش كبير
من الدوله اللبنانيه وارتدادات زلزال
الحرب الذي يضرب
سوريا في استديو الامام والمتخصص في الفقه
الاسلامي ومؤلف كتاب الاسلام ضد التطرف
عبد العالي مامون اهلا بك اهلا وهلا
العلويون كما سمعت وشاهدت يقولون انه هم
من المسلمين ما راي الغالبيه السنيه اليوم
في هذه الطائفه نعم
هناك اولا توضيح لابد ان نبينه فيما يخص
اخذ الموقف تجاه العقائد التي تختلف عن
عقيده اهل السن والجماعه من العلماء
المتشددين الذين راوا الى ضروره النظر الى
تفاصيل الاعتقادات
فاذا اختلف شخص او طائفه عن فصيل
الاعتقادات فانه يخرج من مله الاسلام
ويعتبر كافرا لا لا علاقه له مع الاسلام
والاغلبيه المعتدله تقول ان لا المفروض ان
نسال فقط عن
اي العقيده الاجماليه هل يؤمن بالله هل
يؤمن باركان الاسلام هل يؤمن با باركان
الايمان ان تؤمن بالله وملائكته و كتبه
نعم هذا سمعناه فالاصل فيهم انهم مسلمون
الا اننا نختلف مع معهم والواجب كحن
اغلبيه في العالم الاسلامي ان نتحاور معهم
وان نتعايش معهم وان نحتضن وان نقدر لهم
الام سنناقش تفاصيل الاختلافات التي يمكن
قد تكون يعني موجوده بين الغالبيه وبين
هذه الطائفه على تويتر سالنا ماذا تعرفون
عن الطائفه العلويه ومن اصل حوالي 1200
شخص شاركوا في هذا الاستطلاع 40% قالوا لا
اعرف شيئا عن هذه الطائفه وهم الغالبيه و
33% قالوا انها ديانه قائمه بحد ذاتها و27
بال قالوا انها مذهب من مذاهب الاسلام بعد
الفاصل الاخباري هل يقدس العلويون الامام
علي بن ابي طالب ويفضلونه على النبي محمد
وهل ما يروج من صور نمطيه عنهم فيه شيء من
الصحه في فلك الممنوع نعود بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
back
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى فرانس بكات كم تذكيرا بابرز
العناوين الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب
يلوح بالانسحاب من اتفاقيه باريس حول
المناخ والاتحاد وال الاوروبي والصين
وروسيا تؤكد دعمها
للاتفاق قواه الحشد الشعبي تحقق انتصارات
متلاحقه عبر استعاده السيطره على الشريط
الحدودي بين العراق وسوريا في غرب
الموصل دعوه جديده لتظاهر يوم الاحد
المقبل امام البرلمان في الرباط للمطالبه
باطلاق سراح المعتقلين على خلفيه حراك
الريف شكرا على المتابعه والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ن